fighting for his life Matthew Perry
opening up in startling detail about his
journey with addiction welcome everyone
to Entertainment Tonight You know
despite being on the biggest show in the
world and earning millions of dollars in
the process Matthew struggles with drugs
and alcohol where constant demon that
nearly cost him everything
I'm always drawn to characters that
start out from somewhat broken Place
mostly it was drinking yeah and uh and
opiates how did you get the courage to
fight the addiction to Vicodin you get
into a place in your life where you're
having a problem and you either you know
lie down about it or step up to Baton
take your uh take your swing 15 stints
in rehab 55 vicodin pills a day and 14
surgeries related to his addiction I
think I was pretty good at hiding it you
know but you know eventually people were
aware
[Music]
three-year-old who was last seen in
public last August at the U.S open gets
candid in a new Memoir friends lovers
and the big terrible thing People
magazine out Friday has excerpts the
revelations
Matt says that his substance abuse
caused his weight to vary dramatically
over the 10 seasons of Friends from 128
pounds to 225. he credits his castmates
though with saving him quote they were
understanding and they were patient I
can still hear the screaming Matt seemed
to be slurring his words during the
taping of last year's friend's reunion
the actor does not address the rumors in
the leaked excerpts but a report at the
time claimed he had just had emergency
dental surgery I felt like I was gonna
die if they didn't laugh and it's not
healthy for sure but I would sometimes
say a line and they wouldn't laugh and I
would sweat and and just like just go
into convulsions his lowest point Matt
says his colon burst in 2018 from opioid
overuse quote the doctors told my family
that I had a two percent chance to live
Matt spent two weeks in a coma and five
months in the hospital and had to use a
colostomy bag for nine months he writes
my therapist said the next time you
think about taking Oxycontin just think
about having a colostomy bag for the
rest of your life
as for match recovery today well he
prefers not to reveal his exact clean
time but says he had to be quote pretty
safely sober and away from the active
disease of alcoholism and addiction to
work on the Memoir that's what I have to
do because there's so much out there
that I like
[Music]